[Musique]
une session de recrutement a été
organisée par le knarm en partenariat
avec le cfka et le CFA afin de permettre
à de jeunes réunionnés de bénéficier
d'une formation en métropole environ une
vingtaine de candidats ont été retenus
un bilan jugé positif on a recruté 18
jeunes Réunionnais qui son répartisent
en 9 BTS et 9 bacprommerce donc on a des
jeunes gens vraiment très bien très
épant on a rencontré plein de jeunes
gens très bien toute la semaine
d'ailleurs après c'est le projet de
mobilité et l'intégration en métropole
qui qui a souvent fait le choix de la
sélection
finale gér une parité entre garçons et
filles on a autant de filles que de
garçons des projets plutôt aussi un
petit peu différents avec je dirais des
des jeunes qui ont envie d'aller dans
les commerces de proximité alimentaire
que ce soit CR fromagerie ça c'est ça
commence vraiment à se démocratiser on
est assez content là-dessus parce que
nous on a des des très très bons
employeurs sur sur la métropole sur ce
secteur d'activité des jeunes dans dans
le secteur de la chocolaterie dans le
secteur un peu de la grande distribution
dans les pièceries de qualité aussi donc
en fait on a vraiment des profils qui
peuvent correspondre parfaitement à
notre à nos partenaires et je pense
qu'ils en seront ravis de les rencontrer
de les embaucher une session de
recrutement qui n'a duré que quelques
jours pourtant ce recensement nécessité
des mois de préparation et de filtrage
pour le knnarme bon ben c'est une
semaine un peu compliquée puisqu'on
reçoit beaucoup de monde c'est un
travail qui est commencé en amont
puisquon a reçu plus de 170 candidatures
pour ce recrutement au final avec un
filtrage de 60 candidats convoqués et
une réussite de 18 candidats
embauchés la semaine donc c'est divers
groupes et divers entretiens d'embauche
et un accompagnement spécifique pour
chaque candidat sur les entretiens des
jeunes soulagés de voir leur projet
professionnel se concrétiser
désormais ils se préparent à leur départ
pour la métropole malgré l'anxiété de
quitter leurs proches il s'impatientent
de vivre une telle
expérience B bien sûr au début c'est un
peu stresse mais je suis très contente
que mon projet aboutit à quelque chose
et j'ai très hâte de partir parce que je
suis très bien préparé et je sais que ça
va bien ça va bien se passer ils sont
vraiment performants là-dedans et voilà
j'ai très hâte en tout cas la
déépendance sur tout ça
l'autonomie découvrir un nouveau pays un
nouvel environnement c'est un peu dur
effectivement de quitter la famille mais
mais bon c'est pour l'avenir donc on n
pas trop le choix et puis pour moi c'est
une nouvelle expérience aussi puisque
c'est la première fois que je pars en
métropole donc voilà les candidats
retenus s'envoleront pour la métropole
en juin ils signeront leur contrat
d'embauche dès leur
arrivée
[Musique]